la présidente du rassemblement national
en terrain conquis ce dimanche à mantes
la ville unique communes d'île de france
ayant un maire est reine la ville était
une opportunité pour marine le pen de
ranimer des militants encore sonné par
l'échec à la présidentielle en
difficultés financières et judiciaires
le rassemblement national fait sa
rentrée régionales dans une commune dont
la mairie discrète se veut servir
d'exemple pour l'ensemble du territoire
c'est aussi une vitrine de ce qu'on est
capable de faire d'un point de vue
politique d'un point de vue local sur la
sécurité sont les développements la vie
culturelle sur la non augmentation des
impôts pour les militants locaux la
visite de leur présidente jamais venu
auparavant dans la commune est une
opportunité électorale pour le
département on a de plus en plus du
département qui sont favorables marié le
pen
on espère en gagner de plus en plus à
monza a été un grand centre pour le
front national
elle s'est toujours occupé de
l'immigration je pense qu'il y en a
beaucoup trop en france c'est certain et
que si elle pouvait faire quelque chose
j'ai rien contre eux il en faut
malheureusement puisque les peuples ne
veulent plus faire d'enfants avec
seulement une dizaine de communes est
reine en france marine le pen marquer le
coup avec manque la ville malgré les
honneurs faits au maire cyril notes et à
sa commune la présidente était de courts
passages et n'aura pas rencontré ses
habitants
[Applaudissements]